Цей чоловік хоче бути українським президентом. Але це не те, що носить сильний лідер.
Костюм пошили не на вас, містер Порошенко!
Це виглядає, як піжама!
Суміш бабусі та школярки, яка хоче бути найкращою в класі.
Це гарний вигляд, особливо для молодого політика. Гольф з піджаком.
Це не так формально, як костюм і краватка.
Це ближче до людей.
Але при цьому немає відкритої шиї. Шия прикрита.
Стильний вигляд.
Це теж.
Але оце - велика помилка.
Не можна чоловікові за 35, який хоче, щоб його обрали…
О, ще й поголитися треба.
Не можна носити те, що немає комірців, як це.
Це ж виглядає, як піжама.
Він грає президента у телесеріалі і носить там костюми з краватками постійно.
І це саме та картинка, яку бачать люди.
Вони голосують не за актора, а за образ, який бачать.
І цей образ - президент, якого він грає на телебаченні,
і він постійно носить костюм з краваткою.
Я б рекомендував не показувати, що насправді я не той чоловік,
а більше вдаватися до образу, який вже сформувався у людей про нього.
Цей же образ не дуже для політика.
Якщо ти хочеш стати вчителем року, можна ще так зробити,
але якщо ти хочеш стати президентом такої держави як Україна, ти маєш показати,
що ти здатний мати справу з Володимиром Путіним,
бути на одному рівні з такими людьми, як Анґела Меркель.
А от пан Порошенко. Він добре вправляється. Він виглядає доволі по-президентськи.
Це те, що він завжди робить.
Червона або синя краватка - це безпечний вибір. Класика жанру.
Цим він каже: я ваш президент, ви знаєте мене, я виглядаю, як президент.
Як президент, якого ви вже знаєте певний час.
Це стабільність, я управляю країною, все стабільно, не робіть експериментів.
Але костюм виглядає надто широким. І не дуже добре сидить ось тут.
Пан Порошенко - він насправді повинен як президент України,
який представляє країну за кордоном, він повинен носити індивідуально пошиті костюми.
Але він цього не робить, як мені здається.
Тому що ви можете побачити, що його костюми не сидять належним чином.
У нього часто видно прогалину між комірцем сорочки та піджаком.
Коли людина стоїть і це видно - це завжди ознака того, що костюм не сидить добре.
Також часто видно, що ця частина топорщиться ось так.
Це також означає, що костюм не на вас пошили.
Моя порада панові Порошенку:
ви маєте дозволити собі костюм, пошитий індивідуально для вас, або два, або п’ять.
Вона не приховує, що вона жінка. Синій колір.
Він передає надійність, довіру і все таке інше. Але жінкам у політиці завжди складно.
Анґелу Меркель багато разів критикували за те, що вона носить те саме,
бо почувається добре у певному типі одягу, що нині вважається своєрідною уніформою Меркель.
Але цього не можна сказати про чоловіків.
Вони носять, що хочуть - костюми і їх за це ніхто не критикує.
Але якщо ти жінка у політиці, треба мати на увазі цей додатковий нюанс і зважати на те, що носиш.
Я не впевнений щодо її зачіски.
Так вона виглядає, як суміш бабусі та школярки, яка хоче бути найкращою в класі.
Складний вибір. Я не експерт з жіночого гардеробу.
Я їй бажаю усього найкращого і я певен, що вона впорається.
Цей чоловік хоче бути українським президентом.
Я б йому порадив…
Мені дуже подобається краватка, але все в одному тоні: блакитне, блакитне і блакитне.
І це не дуже відрізняється від кольору його волосся.
У мене такий же колір волосся, і я б зробив все на контрасті.
Замість блакитної сорочки, я б вдягнув білу.
Просто біла сорочка, і вона б підкреслила краватку краще,
і був би кращий контраст з блакитним костюмом.
Крім того, костюм надто блідий.
Я ж хочу бути президентом країни! А це дуже скромно.
Темніший костюм, біла сорочка і червона краватка, як часто у Порошенка.
Ось - це я! Я буду керувати країною. Повірте мені. Я можу керувати країною.
Наприклад, ось цей.
Якщо ще й взяти білу сорочку.
Вибачте!
Сюди білу сорочку.
Отже вже є певний контраст.
Це просто для ілюстрації, що може зробити біла сорочка.
Це більш динамічно. Більше контрасту.
Більше світлого і темного на контрасті. Це можливий наряд або ще трохи темніше.
Будь-які відтінки синього та сірого пасуватимуть політику.
Натиск та енергія кольору, кураж - все, що ви хочете спроектувати на аудиторію, походить від краватки.
Ця моя не дуже добре пасуватиме політику.
Я б вдягнув більш однорідний колір, а не з таким складним візерунком.
Ця ж краватка насправді непогана, яку б я вдягнув кудись на вечерю або ж для телеведучого.
Але для політика в цьому наряді - це дуже скромно. Краватка гарна, але в цьому образі не дуже.
Подивіться, ви бачите дуже скромну людину. І це добре. Ми ж хочемо скромних політиків чи не так?
Але з іншого боку, ми хочемо політика, яка може повернутися до таких людей,
як Володимир Путін, і сказати: зупинися - я сильний лідер.
А це - не те, що носить сильний лідер.
А тут пан Порошенко зробив велику помилку.
Відкрита шия у костюмі без краватки.
Не дуже вдалий хід.
Порожнеча. Тут чогось бракує.
Так, він намагається виглядати розслабленим, бути ближчим до людей і таке інше.
Нині це дуже популярно серед політиків.
Але я думаю, що це помилка.
Якщо ж ви вже вдягнули костюм і сорочку - зав’яжіть краватку.
Це те, для чого вона зроблена.
Ця прогалина має бути заповнена чимось. Якщо це забрати, буде порожньо.
Це наче рамка без фотографії.
Тож, особливо для політиків завжди добре мати краватку, а не вдавати з себе крутого.